when you had a look at this rate you
noticed before that if you're on between
0 & 3 hours it just tracks all your pets
a murmur if it was three or five hours
you track a little pain okay but there's
plenty of things where we want sort of
the best of both worlds okay we want
this some increasing at a linear rate
but we also want different intervals
different brackets to behave differently
okay now again thinking about money is a
really really common example passenger
with that you might deserve know what it
is it's kind of a mix between or 20
actually it would be it would be I'll
come over here draw this I guess so for
instance suppose you know um you can
work up to three hours okay and then if
you're working more than three hours
we're like one okay you wrote a pretty
hard I'll pay you extra for those
clients of work right because you guys
told me before a steeper gradient means
you're overweight okay but there's a
really important example how much or get
in your textbook but I want to show it
to you now okay and that is tax okay
this is the most common real-life
example and you guys are going to be
well hopefully you'll be earning enough
money to pay tax for most of the rest
your life okay it's important and this
will do tax payable the vertical axis
and will do taxable income which I I
hope you guys um I've heard of the idea
that that is not the same as how much
you actually earn you kind of get tax on
everything so we're going to compare
these two values together and are you
guys where there's a certain amount of
money kind of like with parking that you
can earn and the government will charge
you know interest does anyone know how
much that is it's it's about eighteen
thousand dollars between 18 to 19 from
memories like 18,000 100 or 200
thereabouts ok let's just call it 18 so
from zero dollars right taxable income
all the way over to will call it 18,000
for now k 50 low 40 to 80 thousand they
charge you no tax that's nice
hey how kind of okay but the second year
earned 18001 dollars they start to
charge you but it's not like this then
automatically slap you know some
indiscriminate mouth here what happens
is their only tax the dollars above
18,000 okay so here's what would happen
if for instance you that 18001 dolls
you'd pay a little bit tax if you eighty
thousand to you don't a little bit more
tax and so on so what you're getting is
this okay so you can see how it's kinda
like this graph in that it's got
different behaving chunks right but it's
kind of like this one in that the chunks
are just flat across the top they
increase now you go your next bracket I
think it's about thirty seven thousand
dollars they're about it you guys cannot
check all these numbers unfortunately
every time we get a textbook they change
it every year right so the taxable the
tax brackets will always adjust the
second you hit that threshold you get
taxed more right so what would that mean
for the grade of the line it will be
sleep I would have been so something
like this now by the way these these
numbers here right you can look up what
they are but all I what is the behavior
what's happening over here okay you hit
a new bracket and then you go up and you
get the idea so being that this is not
quite this but it's also i mean if you
if you were like a landscaper you build
step like this you get fired okay so
this is not a step graph right we call
this a piecewise graph or a piecewise
function meaning different pieces of it
are defined in different ways